las labores de rescate continúan en
contrarreloj pero las probabilidades de
encontrar personas con vida se
desvanecen en la ciudad turca de esmirna
sabes he visto personas que han sido
rescatadas después de 72 horas así que
tenemos que tener fe y mantener la
esperanza así no sepamos qué va a pasar
después de nuevo miami milanés esta
ciudad costera fue una de las más
afectadas por el sismo de magnitud 6.9
que se sintió también en grecia bulgaria
y macedonia del norte 20 edificios que
estaban en proceso de transformación
urbana debido a la falta de resistencia
sísmica quedaron completamente
destruidos el ministro de justicia nos
investigaciones y prometió acciones
legales de encontrarse en negligencia en
su construcción este radio de
destrucción ha ampliado el margen de las
operaciones de rescate
estamos adelantando labores de búsqueda
en ocho edificios hasta ahora hemos
encontrado a más de 100 personas con
vida
billings
hoy cerca de la zona de desastre un
campo de fútbol fue transformado en un
gran campamento temporal con más de 3000
tiendas de campaña para comer a los
damnificados
estamos tratando de ayudar quizá un día
estemos en la misma situación
turquía está atravesada por varias
fallas geológicas que la hace propensa a
terremotos los más devastadores los
vivió en 1999 año en el que dos sismos
de gran intensidad mataron a unas 18.000
personas al norte del país